since midnight foreign travelers coming
from the UK and Ireland have been banned
from entering the United States the two
countries were added to the restricted
list after experiencing a surge in
coronavirus cases
Elizabeth Palmer is in London for us
Elizabeth good morning how is the crisis
unfolding in Europe today
well good morning the 27 leaders of the
European countries are all meeting today
not physically by video link to decide
whether to close the entire exterior
border of that zone to all foreign
travelers and that's just the latest in
a whole series of measures here
restricting movement some on gaya' we
are at war
French president Emmanuel macron said as
he announced that as of noon today
French people should only go outdoors to
buy necessities or to get to work
schools restaurants and cafes have been
closed in Britain to the Prime Minister
announced new measures it looks as
though we're now approaching the fast
growth part of the upward curve and
without drastic action cases could
double every five or six days to slow it
down people here are being encouraged to
avoid public spaces though pops
restaurants and even gyms are still open
Spain which saw an explosion of cases
last week is virtually shut down and at
European land borders Travel is set to
be further restricted and in some places
shut down completely Italy which has
been especially hard-hit is still
struggling to bring the infection rate
under control and Italians are learning
to cope with a new reality every two
days we take a walk learn Chinese
medical workers have arrived in Italy to
share their experiences with the
Italians
but the w-h-o says beating this virus
depends on one key thing we have a
simple message for all countries test
test test
now the message coming from every layer
of government all authorities medical
people is that things here are going to
get a lot worse before they get better
but there is a little ray of hope coming
out of the place where this all kicked
off in Wuhan in China today reporting
one new case Anthony it is good news
Elizabeth Palmer in London thanks Liz